und du gehst hin und stellt mich auf
diese art los ein mega macht durch an
einen weißen zu treffen auf meinem boden
der nation ist ein film von nature der
sich natürlich bezieht auf den berühmten
ging auf den titel des berühmten
menschen sind von jeder käufer ein
stummfilm von anfang des vergangenen
jahrhunderts der geschichte eines clans
mann erzählte und programm macht
sozusagen das gegenteil er sagt die
geburt der nation ist eine folge des
rassismus auf dem alles aus amerika ist
der film erzählt die geschichte eines
fladen aufstandes 1831 nic.at wird das
als heldengeschichte und nacht als einer
doch ziemlich komplexen und drei namen
fürchterlichen geschichte die mit
göttlicher eingebung und ähnlichen zu
tun hat eine eigentlich ganz einfache
connect ich erzählte geschichte eines
schwarzen helden der sich aufmacht gegen
die weise zu kämpfen sie sämtlich
abzuschlachten bis er jeden fall einer
unübertroffenen unübertrefflichen
übermacht dann seinerseits erledigt
sorgt dass es künstlerisch sehr
bedenklich was er da macht aus vielerlei
gründen bedient einerseits werden
bedient sich sämtliche klischees die wir
aus südstaaten eben kennen und das alles
gut aber ohne und etwas mit diesen
bildern zu machen es über das hinaus was
wir wissen dass in ihre
zeichenhaftigkeit die sagen südstaaten
plantage oder so und dann gibt es das
große problem in diesem film der frauen
es gibt diese szene die eine
schwarze ein passagier ums mädchen auf
dem kleinen markt verkauft wird sich
fürchterlich zugerichtet ganz
offensichtlich schon vielfach
vergewaltigt worden dort angepriesen
pauli zu weiteren vergewaltigung
eingeladen
der besitzer von sap kauft sie dann
quasi für ne tolle der die dann verraten
das ist so wieder dachte ich das
eigentlich der ganze firmen damit schon
erledigt hat wir hörten auf ihn und dann
kommt ja vielleicht so dass damals die
diesen sklavenaufstand keinen großen
unterschied gemacht hat wem er da
eigentlich nieder letzter das wurden
ganze familie niedergemetzelt es gibt
aufzeichnungen darüber bei net kath net
turner hat es sein die geschichte
erzählt während er sozusagen der
todeszelle saß und auf seine eigene
hängung behauptete die geschichte
erzählt und erzählt wie die fit zurück
gegangen sind um die babys auch noch zu
ermorden und so und das kann man nicht
so gut in dieser form eines eines
ungebrochenen heldenepos und auch der
selbstüberhöhung des künstlers der dazu
erzählen ich bin sehr problematisch hält
muss abraten ist klar wir doch die stars
nicht
das kann alles zerstören wofür wir
gearbeitet haben mach dein maul aufbauen
und so fort